12 Std. Flug
sind es von Zürich nach Singapur.
Eine wertvolle Zeit für Seilbahn-
direktor Bernhard Tschannen,
um sich vorzubereiten -
auf den Kampf
um die asiatischen Touristen.
Ja, es ist ein Kampf.
Es gibt ein Hauptziel,
das wir alle in der Schweiz haben:
dass die Gäste
mal in die Schweiz kommen.
Nach Europa, in die Schweiz.
Aber dann ist es ein harter Kampf,
welchen Berg sie
in der Schweiz besuchen.
Sein Berg ist das Gipfelmassiv
zwischen dem waadtländischen
Les Diablerets und Gstaad.
Das Gebiet trägt
den Marketingnamen Glacier 3000.
Ursprünglich war es v.a.
als Gletscher-Skigebiet bekannt.
Doch Skifahrer sind hier
inzwischen in der Minderheit.
Es dominieren die Fussgänger.
V.a. aus Asien.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonklänge *
* Kreischen *
Viele Gäste haben hier ihr
erstes Erlebnis mit Schnee und Eis.
Geboten wird ihnen
eine Unterhaltungsinfrastruktur,
die Kritiker
als Alpen-Disneyland bezeichnen.
Sie kostet 1'500 Fr.
Wie viel es braucht, um die Asiaten
auf den Schweizer Berg zu bringen?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Hi.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonklänge *
Singapur, der Stadtstaat
mit knapp 6 Mio. Einwohnern.
Nahe am Äquator,
tropisch-feuchtes Klima.
Temperaturen um die 30 °C.
Für Bernhard Tschannen
ein heisses Pflaster.
Hier läuft sein Business
nämlich schlechter
als in anderen asiatischen Staaten.
Das soll sich jetzt ändern.
* Dynamische, asiatische Klänge *
Das ist eigentlich
ein Shopping Center,
das quasi auf Reisen,
Europareisen spezialisiert ist.
Lustigerweise
sind die alle beieinander.
Asien gilt nach wie vor als Markt
mit riesigem Touristen-Potenzial.
Aber auch die Konkurrenz
schläft nicht.
Kaum ein Fleck der Welt,
der hier nicht angeboten wird.
Auch Schweizer Berge
haben sich hier fest etabliert.
Insbesondere Jungfrau und Titlis.
Hier ist aber nur der Titlis drauf.
- Ja.
Genau.
Das kommt immer wieder mal vor.
Ziel ist ja nicht,
dass alle auf einen Berg gehen.
Trifft Sie das?
- Nein, das ist gut.
Titlis, Jungfrau
sind auch schöne Ausflugziele.
Aber Glacier 3000 ist auch schön.
Und das wollen wir verkaufen.
Das wollen wir pushen.
Die müssen nicht alle zu uns kommen.
Das Ziel ist,
dass sie zwei, drei Berge abdecken.
Dann ist das schon gut.
Tschannen versucht, die asiatischen
Touristenströme umzulenken:
von der Achse Mailand-Luzern-Titlis
in Richtung Genfersee-Gebiet.
(Englisch)
Okay, hier haben wir Genf.
Wenn Sie von Mailand kommen, nehmen
Sie die Autobahn nach Martigny.
Dann gehen wir auf den Glacier 3000.
Die ganze Reise dauert 5 Std. -
mit Pipistop.
Dann, um 13 Uhr,
Mittagessen auf dem Berggipfel.
Übernachtung in Montreux.
Am nächsten Tag können wir eine
Schifftour auf dem Genfersee machen.
Mit einem Besuch
des Olympischen Museums in Lausanne
und dem Schloss Chillon.
Dann noch eine Übernachtung. Danach
Shopping und weiter nach Paris.
Paris, yes. Yes, good.
Die Skandinavier
waren offensichtlich auch schon hier.
Sie stehen hoch im Kurs.
In Milan? Okay. So we're here.
- Yes, after Milan ...
Bisher
waren die populären Destinationen
natürlich im zentralen Westeuropa.
Schweiz, Paris,
Deutschland oder Holland.
Aber heute suchen unsere Kunden
oft exotischere Ziele.
Island steht ganz hoch im Kurs
oder Finnland.
Die Gäste wollen
die Nordlichter sehen, die Aurora.
Da hat eine richtige Jagd darauf
eingesetzt.
Das ist eine neue Art von Jagd.
Es ist tatsächlich sehr schön,
ich hab's schon gesehen.
Ja, wunderbar.
Die grünen und violetten Farben.
Diese Firma bringt jährlich
rund 3'000 Gäste in die Schweiz.
Bald soll auch
Les Diablerets im Programm sein.
Hier ist der USB-Stick
mit den neuen Fotos.
Ich würde empfehlen,
dass Sie unsere Hängebrücke als
Highlight-Foto ins Programm nehmen.
Alright.
- Thank you.
Thank you. See you. Bye.
- See you. Bye, bye.
Wie bringt man jemanden dazu,
der bis jetzt Titlis und Jungfrau
besucht hat oder in anderen
europäischen Destinationen war,
auf den Glacier zu kommen?
In unserem Fall ist es ja so,
dass wir uns auf diese Gruppen
spezialisiert haben.
Wir haben
zusätzliche Aktivitäten eingebaut.
Dadurch spezialisieren wir uns.
Das ist das kleine Plus,
das die Qualität
des Produkts ausmacht.
Zusätzlich ist es dann einfach
ein Verkaufen, Verkaufen, Verkaufen.
Yes, Sir.
- Hello, hi.
I'm Bernhard from Glacier 3000.
Sorry?
- From Glacier 3000.
Ah, yes.
- I have a meeting with Cindy.
(Frau) How have you been?
- Very good and you?
Ah, okay.
- Busy?
It's a little bit quiet now.
Die Reisebüros
sind nicht immer leicht zu finden.
Und das bei der Hitze.
Immer wieder eine Herausforderung
für den Berner Oberländer.
... three, seven, eight ...
Äh ... sorry, can I ...
The 0378 MICE-matters, is it here?
Sorry?
- This one?
I'm not sure. Maybe you can check.
- Okay.
Das sieht jetzt aber
eher drittklassig aus.
Oder täuscht das?
- Das täuscht.
Das ist einer der grössten MICE-
Anbieter für Incentive-Gruppen.
Was heisst das?
Das sind Geschäftsgruppen,
Konferenzen, die sie anbieten.
Und da haben wir eine Gruppe
von 350 Leuten im Sommer 2019.
Die kommen auf den Glacier 3000
und werden mehrere Nächte
in Lausanne schlafen,
im Beau-Rivage Palace.
Hello. Good to see you.
Wollen Sie vielleicht etwas Wasser?
Ja, gerne. Wasser wäre sehr nett.
Es ist kühl.
Ja, mit der air conditioning
muss man aufpassen,
dass man nicht krank wird.
Ich trage immer
ein T-Shirt unter dem Hemd.
Und dann musst du deinen Sitzplatz
strategisch aussuchen,
damit du nicht direkt
im Wind der air con bist.
Das ist der Film mit den Highlights.
Sehr kurz. Er zeigt die ganze Reise.
Just as a refresh.
Er startet mit dem Glacier 3000.
Man fährt
mit der grossen Seilbahn hoch.
Dann auf die Hängebrücke Peak Walk.
Sie laufen
wirklich durch den Himmel.
Sie können den Mont Blanc, das
Matterhorn und die Jungfrau sehen.
Es gibt viele Aktivitäten im Schnee.
Das Restaurant Botta,
designt von Mario Botta.
* Abenteuerliche Klänge
aus dem Film *
Sind denn die Berge
und der Schnee allein nicht genug?
Nein. Es braucht
Aktivitäten, Unterhaltung.
Man muss die Besucher beschäftigen.
Unsere Kunden geniessen das.
Ansonsten würden sie höchstens
schnell einen Schneemann bauen.
Und das wär's dann.
Man muss sie unterhalten.
Ich denke, das Angebot dort ist gut.
Aber der Hauptgrund sollten dennoch
die Berge, der Schnee
und die Schweiz sein.
Aber es braucht ein paar Extras,
ein paar Abenteuer.
Dinge, die man
in Singapur nicht machen kann.
Fantastic. Okay.
- It's good.
Let's go.
- Good, let's go.
Mittagszeit in Singapur.
Irgendwie
scheinen die fleissigen Asiaten
aber nicht so recht
zur Ruhe zu kommen.
Einen Businesslunch
gibt es auch für Bernahrd Tschannen.
Bestellt
wird übrigens auf dem Tablett.
* Stimmengewirr *
Bernhard Tschannen verbringt jährlich
rund zwei bis drei Monate in Asien.
Inzwischen etwas weniger,
weil er kürzlich
Vater einer Tochter geworden ist.
Täglich hat er
bis zu einem Dutzend Meetings.
Für Fussmassagen hat er keine Zeit.
Massage, Massage?
- Thank you. Thank you.
You wanna try?
- Next time.
Hi, shoulder massage?
- Hello. Thank you.
Siehst du?
- Das ist aktives Marketing.
Ja, das ist aktives Marketing.
Die holen dich richtig.
Dagegen kommt Glacier 3000 nicht an.
- Ja.
Wir versuchen schon ...
Es ist gleich hier.
Wir versuchen,
unsere Kunden dezenter anzugehen,
aber die machen das gut.
Das nächste Meeting - in der
hintersten Ecke der Reiseagentur.
Hello, hi.
Auch hier
dominiert schon die Jungfrau-Region.
Doch es scheint
ein Erfolgserlebnis zu geben.
Ah, schau!
Hier haben wir den Glacier 3000.
Beautiful picture.
Ein sehr schönes Bild
vom Glacier 3000.
Als Ausflugsziel
kommt Glacier 3000 aber nicht vor.
Ich weiss nicht,
wo sie es reingetan haben.
Bieten Sie überhaupt
eine Rundreise an,
in der Sie
den Glacier 3000 besuchen?
(Mann) Ähm, Nein.
Nein? Okay.
Kann ich die Broschüre mitnehmen?
Very good. Thank you very much.
Es ist nicht ganz klar.
Keine Ahnung,
ob sie wissen, worum es genau geht.
Dort, wo das Foto drin ist,
ist jetzt etwas anderes drin
als der Glacier 3000.
Hintergangen?
- Ja, hintergangen ...
Vielleicht dachten sie,
das sei der Titlis.
Auf die asiatischen Touristen
zu setzen, ist eine Idee,
die in Les Diablerets
aus der Not geboren wurde.
2005 ging das Gletscherskigebiet
Konkurs.
Gutbetuchte Geschäftsleute
aus Gstaad kauften die Firma auf.
Unter ihnen Ex-Formel-1-Chef
Bernie Ecclestone.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen
berichtete damals darüber.
(Originalton)
Die grossen Gondeln auf den Gipfel
sind erst ein paar Jahre alt, wie
auch die spektakuläre Bergstation,
die der Tessiner Stararchitekt
Mario Botta teuer gestaltet hat.
Alle Versuche, das Wintersportgebiet
zum Erfolg zu bringen,
sind bisher gescheitert. Nun richtet
man mit der grossen Kelle an.
Die beiden Männer
haben das nötige Geld.
Links Marcel Bach,
Immobilier aus Gstaad,
und Formel-1-Chef Bernie Ecclestone.
Es weht heute ein rauer Wind. Marcel
Bach will aber ganz hoch hinauf.
Wir wollen eine
der grösseren Destinationen werden -
wie Jungfraujoch oder Titlis.
Um die Grossen einzuholen,
liessen die neuen Investoren
u.a. eine lange Rodelbahn bauen -
die höchste der Welt, sagt man hier.
Aber auch in den Ausbau
des Skigebietes investierten sie.
Insgesamt Investitionen
von über 30 Mio. Fr.
An Weihnachten trafen wir
Bernie Ecclestone in Gstaad wieder -
begleitet von seiner
brasilianischen Ehefrau Fabiana
und von Immobilier Marcel Bach.
Fabiana Graft is open.
- Yes, I'm on my way with his card.
Der inzwischen 88-jährige Ecclestone
ist zufrieden,
dass das Gletscherskigebiet
erhalten blieb -
auch dank der asiatischen Fussgänger.
Ich finde, es ist super. Tschannen
hat ganze Arbeit geleistet.
Er macht das Gletschergebiet
weltweit bekannter.
Es ist mir
in den letzten Tagen aufgefallen,
dass viele Inder
hier in den Ferien sind.
Yeah, yeah.
Ja. Heute hatten wir
z.B. 15 Gruppen oben.
Aus Indonesien, Thailand,
Singapur, China und anderen Ländern.
Diejenigen,
die hier investiert haben,
taten das in erster Linie für
die Region, nicht als Investment.
Vielleicht
gibt das mal einen Return.
Gegenwärtig sind wir froh,
wenn wir überleben und investieren
können und wenn alles funktioniert.
Die Anzahl asiatischer Gäste
hat um das 15-fache zu genommen.
Aber man ist noch weit entfernt
vom Titlis oder der Jungfrau.
Darum kämpft Tschannen
weiter um jeden Gast -
heute begleitet er
eine Gruppe aus Singapur.
He takes care of Glacier 3000.
Ein herzliches Willkommen
euch allen.
Wir gehen zuerst in den dritten
Stock. Da gibt es Toiletten.
Dann gehen wir
zur Hängebrücke Peak Walk.
Keine Angst, sie ist sicher.
Meine Mutter hat Höhenangst,
ging aber dennoch drüber.
Ihr schafft das.
Von hier aus kommt ihr durch
das Uhren- und Souvenirgeschäft.
Und dann runter zum Gletscher.
Dort gibt es den Schnee-Fun-Park
und Hundeschlitten mit den Huskys.
Dann kommt ihr zurück
und es gibt das Mittagessen.
(Frau) Are we ready to go up?
- (Alle) Yeah!
* Sanfte, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Sie sehen hier den Mont Blanc,
das Matterhorn und die Jungfrau.
Also alle drei bekannten Gipfel
Europas sind von hier aus sichtbar.
Heute sind sie aber im Nebel.
Smile!
Yes! Oh, wait, wait, wait!
Wofür braucht es
solche Sachen wie diese Brücke?
Das ist das Zusatzangebot.
Man kommt hoch.
Man verbindet
zwei Gipfel miteinander.
Nebst dem natürlichen Ausflugsziel,
nebst der natürlichen Schönheit,
braucht es noch ein paar Aktivi-
täten, um das Ganze aufzupeppen.
Aufgepeppt wird auch
mit einem Pistenfahrzeug-Bus
und mit kurzen Hundeschlitten-Touren.
Letztere
kosten stolze 30 Fr. pro Person.
Im Fun Park, einem Schneehang
mit ein paar Schlitten,
amüsiert sich
Familie Goh aus Singapur.
Sie alle
sind das erste Mal in Europa.
* Kreischen, Lachen *
* Lachen *
In Singapur ist es ja
das ganze Jahr über sehr heiss.
Warum gerade hier?
Wir machen hier Ferien.
Meine Jungs wollten
etwas in diesem Stil erleben.
Das können wir daheim nicht machen.
Wir hatten gehört,
dass es hier eine Rodelbahn gibt.
Aber leider
ist die im Winter offenbar zu.
Ja, eigentlich
wollten wir die Rodelbahn erleben.
Das ist ein bisschen enttäuschend.
Nun, wir können ja nicht Ski fahren.
Aber ich denke, diese Schlitten
genügen, um etwas Spass zu haben.
One more time.
Come, let's go!
Nach dem Spiel das Mittagessen.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Trockenfleisch, Rösti, Käse.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonmusik *
Und dann Shopping.
Ohne das gehe bei den Asiaten
gar nichts, sagen die Touristiker.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonmusik *
* Blöken *
Familie Goh
geniesst die Schweizer Folklore.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Und Bernhard Tschannen
bespricht mit dem Chef
des singapurischen Reiseveranstalters
gemeinsame Zukunftsperspektiven.
Ein paar  Wochen später - und mit
ganz anderem Essen auf dem Tisch -
geht diese Diskussion
in Singapur weiter.
Der persönliche Kontakt sei
das A und O im asiatischen Geschäft.
Ist es klar, wer wen einlädt?
Das ist manchmal ein Thema.
Eigentlich laden wir ja gerne ein.
Aber oftmals
wollen sie dann selber einladen.
Das klärt man gegen Schluss.
Aber das Ziel wäre schon,
dass ich sie einlade.
Entscheidet er:
"Wir gehen hier- oder dorthin"?
Ja, das ist,
wie wenn ich in ein Geschäft gehe
und mich für Nudeln, Spaghetti
oder Reis entscheiden kann.
Sie können entscheiden,
auf welchen Berg sie gehen.
Ob Titlis oder Les Diablerets,
wird dann auch schon mal bei
einem Bier in Singapur entschieden.
Es ist ein harter Kampf
um die asiatischen Touristen.
Für manche Schweizer Bergbahn
sind die Asiaten
die grössten Hoffnungsträger.
Darum werden sie oft
auch mit niedrigen Preisen angelockt.
Tschannen spricht von Preisdumping.
Man muss leider sagen,
ja, es gibt ein Preisdumping.
Es gibt Bergbahnen,
die verkaufen ihren Berg zu einem
Viertel des Schweizer Preises -
oder sogar zu einem Fünftel.
Das ist
eine grosse Konkurrenz für uns
und bringt uns
auch etwas in Bedrängnis.
Die Frage,
die sich dann jeder stellt, ist:
Ziehe ich mit oder gibt es
eine gewisse Schmerzgrenze,
die ich nicht unterschreite,
auch wenn ich das Business verliere
oder
viel langsamer wachse als andere?
Tschannen reist von Singapur
weiter nach Thailand und Indonesien.
Wir machen einen Besuch
in einem Aussenquartier von Singapur.
Hier wohnt die Familie Goh.
Sie sind seit ein paar Wochen
zurück von ihrer Europa-Reise
und auch vom Les-Diablerets-Massiv.
Mein Vater mit seinem Schneemann.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonmusik im Video *
Mir gefiel die Musik. Die ist gut.
Ihre Schweiz-Bilanz
mit etwas Distanz:
sehr schön,
nette Menschen, aber auch sehr teuer.
Und dann noch
eine etwas überraschende Kritik:
Wir in Singapur
sind ja streng mit der Sauberkeit.
Wir versuchen,
nichts einfach wegzuwerfen.
Z.B. das Papier
von Kaugummis oder Süssigkeiten
werfen wir gerne in den Abfall.
Und es gibt dafür überall Eimer.
In der Schweiz war das schwieriger.
Da mussten wir manchmal die Abfälle
in unsere Taschen stecken.
Und auch Toiletten
waren schwierig zu finden.
Les Diablerets Mitte Februar.
Tschannen
ist wieder aus Asien zurück.
Nach dem eher schwierigen Beginn
in Singapur sei die Verkaufsreise
in Thailand und Indonesien
erfolgreich verlaufen.
Indonesien kommt gut.
Und Thailand kommt sehr gut.
Da haben wir grosse Schritte gemacht
die letzten zwei Jahre.
Es sollte dieses Jahr
nochmals 20-25 % Wachstum geben.
Wir haben in Thailand
den König, der verstorben ist.
Der hat ja in Lausanne gelebt.
Und daraus kannst du eine schöne
Geschichte machen, mit Lausanne,
wo der König gelebt hat -
das wollen die Thais noch sehen.
Mit dem Glacier 3000, dem Golden-
pass und anderen Produkten.
Das kommt sehr gut an im Markt.
Geschichten,
Schnee und Spiele für die Asiaten.
Die Skifahrer
sind inzwischen auf dem zweiten Rang.
So sieht der Wintertourismus
in Zukunft aus -
zumindest hier
zwischen Les Diablerets und Gstaad.